ja weiß warum ich so viel geld habe weil
ich mach youtube-videos und dann kriegt
einfach zu viel geld er etwas klappt
jetzt bekommen beim ein video ist jetzt
wahrscheinlich schon wieder heute geht
es mal wieder um chatroulette ich habe
gerade auch so dass napster gepostet ihr
euch bin jetzt topfit und will mal
gucken ob jetzt in anlagen von euch
treffe ich habe keinen plan was ich
jetzt gleich machen werde
ich hoffe es wird einiges unterhalts
haben wir gehen einfach mal an die sache
ran vielleicht ja heute eine
telefonnummer
ich glaube schon gar nicht mehr aber wir
können sie dann auf suchen
letztlich würde gerade auf jeden fall
bis zum ende dran zu bleiben weil da
noch was ganz wichtig ist und im ja ich
kann es ja schon mal so ein bisschen
vorher verraten
seid wirklich aufmerksam während des
videos und lässt der vater
deswegen bleiben wir aber den hast du
auch so ein cooles teil
jetzt habt ihr euer hot kannst du das
nicht ich bin auch seinen preis hat
neben angeklopft habe ja weiß warum ich
so viel geld ab weil ich mach
youtube-videos und dann krieg ich
einfach zu viel geld
hallo
wie heißt wie heißt du habt ihr die
anderen stadt folgen abgesehen
und was meint ihr wochen läuft das so
dass ich meine nummer bekommen wie an
seite so stimmt es dass sie 16 uhr steht
das dann nur so
damit das besser rüberkommt damit ihr
auch die 20-jährigen klären können weil
das ist ja sonst strafbar schwarze
sonnenbrille wie ein blues brother ich
sehe aus was geht was
blockbuster und jetzt den richtigen
namen
heute finde ich eben ich habe gerade
auch schon 2 getroffen die man auf 16
und verfolgt immer so meine videos und
was würdest du sagen was ich falsch
gemacht habe die letzten folgen warum
ich keine nur gekriegt hat du hast hier
über eine geklärt mit 14 ja ja ja war
läuft bei dir nicht schlecht also mit 14
konnte ich das noch nicht aber dass es
langsam angehen
zeig mal nicht wenig hattet ihr nun
profilbild drin oder radio mit
vielleicht war es auch ein mann wenn ich
jetzt meinen anhalte willst du nicht
auch denke ich mir mein blick aber nicht
schlecht hast mein respekt war weiter so
warum macht ihr können nicht sagen da
die heißt hier im felix glaub mir nicht
sicher
ja ich kenne ich also komm ich sage
eigentlich eigentlich weiß alex aber
eigentlich heißt felix
aber sagt das können ja aber wenn ich
dich ja zum beispiel zensieren würde
dann wäre das ja total langweilig weil
du willst du bist jetzt auch nicht
hässlich oder sowieso willst und
zensiert werden
das war gerade voll das kompliment mit
dem fall seit jetzt extra wegen mir aus
stockach ich dachte schon
auch keine nummer nicht zugesagt noch
mal verstanden aber ja ich hab sie alles
zu sparen und also vorher ließ sich
blockbuster und jetzt weiß ich alex v
alex wie soll das auszusprechen
ausgesprochen werden doch als ob jetzt
gibst du dein youtube wo das friends du
hast da nicht wirklich doch nicht stehen
oder doch ist um von meinem bruder ein
gott der prinz das noch mein büro willst
wird sollte seine nummer geben dann
könnt ihr euch gleich mal kennenlernen
so vom prinzen warte warte warte warte
warte warte weiter du musst du musst
okay leute ich würd mal sagen das reicht
jetzt auch so langsam auf jeden fall war
in diesem video denn ganz wichtiges wort
versteckt wenn ihr es gefunden habt oder
sonst schauen wir noch mal nach dann
schreibt euch das auch und jetzt nicht
vergessen oder macht es auf jeden fall
die lobby haben halt auch oder jetzt
gerade auch ein video hochgeladen
checkt das auf jeden fall ab ist hier
verlinkt oder auch in der infobox
verlinkt links ist hier genau überlegt
und ja es hat noch ein zweites mal
verschlägt das müsst ihr euch auf jeden
fall raus suchen beschreibt euch das
laub dann könnt ihr was gewinnen
schreibt einfach in die kommentare beide
bird haft und da wollte ich gar nicht
sagen wir sind nicht nur noch mit
abonnieren vergessen noch nicht in rente
haut rein leute etwas gut egal